On a tiny copper globe created in the early 1500s,...
...the coast of Southeast Asia is marked with a message....
...that has since become iconic: "Here be dragons."
Though the words themselves were actually quite rare,...
...the sentiment was common among medieval European mapmakers,...
...who often scrawled dragons and sea monsters...
...over terra incognita, blank spots on the map.
For thousands of years, people all over the world...
...had made both functional maps,...
...showing trade routes, settlements, topography, water sources,...
...the shapes of coastlines or written directions,...
...and what are known as cosmographies,...
...illustrating the Earth and its position in the cosmos,...
...often including constellations, gods and mythic locations.
From the Middle Ages through the mid-17th century,...
...cartographers in Eurasia and North Africa...
...produced a slew of New World maps with features from both these traditions,...
...often commissioned by rulers and other powerful people.
These maps were meant to depict the world's geography,...
...but not necessarily to be useful for navigation.
And given their maker's incomplete knowledge of the world,...
...they were really hypotheses, some of which have been glaringly disproven.
In medieval Europe, the new vogue began with what were known as "mappae mundi."
Many of these veered closer to cosmographies,...
...featuring the Garden of Eden, or mythical dragons.
They all followed the same format,...
...showing the world's land as one mass divided roughly...
...into the shape of a T and surrounded by a ring of ocean.
Islamic mapmakers also created world maps in this format,...
...emphasizing geographic details over fantastical elements.
One of the earliest and most accurate such maps was created by Ibn Hawqal,...
...whose own travels informed his mapmaking.
In 1154, the King of Sicily commissioned Islamic mapmaker Al-Idrisi...
...to create the Tabula Rogeriana,...
...also known as "A Guide to Pleasant Journeys into Faraway Lands."
This book of maps included a world map based on Idrisi's own travel...
...and interviews with other traders and travelers.
He correctly depicted the world as a flattened sphere,...
...but thought Europe, Asia, and North Africa wrapped all the way around it.